As he faces scrutiny from lawmakers and regulators at home and abroad,...
...Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg announced a rebrand of the company he founded in 2004.
Our company is now "Meta."
The name change comes as the world's largest social media company...
...battles criticism over its market power, algorithm and abuse on its platforms.
Speaking at the company's live-streamed virtual and augmented reality conference,...
...Zuckerberg said it reflects the company's ambition to build the "metaverse,"...
...which it bets will be the successor to the mobile internet.
A term coined in a dystopian novel three decades ago...
...and now buzzing in Silicon Valley,...
..."metaverse" refers broadly to the idea of a shared virtual environment.
The company, which has invested heavily in augmented and virtual reality,...
...said the change would bring together its different apps and technologies...
...under one new brand and would not change its corporate structure.